uh but a lot of what I hear you're
talking about is really what zne does
for email tungle does for calendar you
know and zne has been uh quite effective
at mining uh Trends and information and
data about your email that you use every
day and you're on top of it and you
think you know but there's a lot you
don't know there's a lot of analytics
and trends that you don't see so
applying those same things to a calendar
could be pretty interesting so I think
zne really open my eyes on that part of
analytics of email cuz again you're in
email every single day and you're on top
of it and you're responsive and you
think you know but until you see those
analytics and you say oh my God I didn't
realize that I was these five people are
the you know 80% of my time of of who
I'm sending email to I think if you did
the same thing to a calendar to know
where you're spending your time yeah uh
that would be huge tripet tries to do
that uh um with travel so that it has
your Airline reservation your rental car
your hotel your everything all in one
spot M uh but for me I'm a calendar guy
so I would rather go to my calendar and
see there's my rental car uh reservation
number there's my hotel reservation
there's my flight cuz I want to be on my
phone right and just click on the
calender and see everything get it all
everything there I don't want to have to
go to email and search for
uh the vendor the particular vendor and
find out okay which CU if I do a search
on Herz I've got 30 of them right and I
got to figure which one is it it's that
one or you know that kind of stuff so
tripet tries to aggregate that data for
trips in a separate application I don't
want to go to a separate application I'd
rather have it in the calendar so you
know if there's a way to do that that'
be awesome